哪个终于两周之后又和大家又见面了
哪个休息的很不错
然后呢
但是最后课程准备还是非常的
这个这个很多的事
突然发现网络也是很复杂的
没关系
我们每一节课开始的时候
最近都是用我们的哪个T恤作为我们的开场了
对吧
这个T恤大家都很期待
告诉大家一个好消息
就是我们这个T恤的话呢
现在已经送去生产了
大概可能还需要三周左右
所以大家千万要稍安勿躁啊
然后呢同学们哪个另外一个就是同学们的话
我们上一次上两次
我们哪个就是在我们的评论区里面
我们的留言的同学们
我们哪个已经挑出了我们幸运的小伙伴
然后的话这是我们的名单
然后同学们都能找到我们课程组呢
就是在群里面加入我们的小秘书AMANDA对吧
然后他会把你的联系方式啊
你的地址告诉他
然后呢他我们会等这个T恤记好啊
打哪个印好之后
我们就给大家寄过去
另外一个的话呢
就是说我们再想了一下
就是不只是在咱们B站课上留言
包括我们同学们做我们的作业
如果连续能做完两次作业
就做完两次作业的同学的话
我们课程组商量一下
说也给大家发一个T恤做个纪念
因为其实每一个作业都比较难
它不像那么简单的一个算法对吧
然然后呢
因为考虑到大家现在时间
就是前一段时间特别的忙
要准备期末考试
所以呢我们非常贴心的把我们的课程的
所有的deadline全部设到了8月31号
那8月30号第二天是什么
9月1号
也就是在开学前
大家把作业做好就可以了
那么大家加油啊
争取能够拿到我们的哪个课程组的T恤
那么OK另外一个的话呢
其实自从我们开始这个稍等诶
我的这个翻译器好像有点坏了
稍等
那我要用鼠标了
稍等一下啊
啊完了完了
我今天哪个翻译器好像有问题没事
那然后的话呢
就是说其实呢最近这段时间我们开哪个开始
我们的这个就是B站小留言的活动时
通讯给我留言留的蛮有意思的
包括有同学跟我们讲说我们这PKO的引擎的话
好像跟红猪宫崎骏的动画
红猪哪个你们的哪个一模一
哪个哪个哪个修飞机的飞机场一模一样
诶
其实我听到这个留言之后
我自己今天下午还把哪个
宫崎骏的动画也看了一下
因为宫崎老爷子的动画片一直是我最喜欢的
我觉得真的他能给我们激发
我们心里面非常美好的东西
所以我觉得一如既往吧
还是那么感动
然后的话呢其实同学们的留言中
我能感受到一种温暖温暖吧
因为其实我们在做这个104课程的时候
很多时候呢我们也不知道我们的目的是什么
说实话我也没有刻意的去想过
我们2014课程是目的是什么
但是我觉得我希望同学们真的能够享受
这样的一个104课程的这样的一个快乐
也就是说呃大家的话呢在这个课程中的话呢
就是说真的能享受作为一个游戏引擎
做这样的一个就是说能够享受一下上帝的感觉
你可以自由地创造这个世界
我并不一定要成为这个世界上最牛的游戏引擎
引擎的研发者对吧
如果我做那么一个小小的功能
诶
天空因为我变得很蓝
我看到了绚丽的彩霞
我看到我的小人按照我的方式去动起来了
甚至开始跟我互动
那种快乐真的是发自内心的
我记得我在读书的时候
那个时候就开始去写游戏嘛
很小的时候在大学的时候
然后我记得那时我写了一个足球的AI游戏
然后我就看着他两边AI在踢足球
可以看一晚上
就每天其实很无聊的
你就看左边右边啊
A队赢还是B队赢
当时我还特别有意思的说
这是中国队
这是美国队对吧
那我肯定会很很下意识的
把咱们中国队的这个球技调的那么强
那么一点点
虽然事实上是反的对吧
那么其实这就是做游戏引擎的一个快乐
就是说你真的能够去创造这个世界
那另外的话呢就是说
所以我希望我们的同学们的话呢
能够真的尽情的享受这个过程
就是keep it simple
就是说不用太多的功力
我学这门课的目的是什么啊
我我一定要怎么样对吧
相反就是说你真的享受这你们知识的乐趣
包括我自己在准备这个104课程的时候
我和我们的课程组
其实从一开始觉得压力满满啊
到现在其实已经变成了一种享受
或者变成了一种生活状态
就是大家每个星期在一起就说诶
这一周我们要讲什么
那我们一起把所有这方面的知识都自己学一遍
然后我们一起讨论会
就问哎这个知识为什么是这样呢对吧
这个东西源头是什么呢
其实我们也是在准备这个课程
一边准备一边跟大家一起去学习
所以啊我觉得做什么都是这样的
就是你去享受它就好
那么好好啦
那废话不多说
那还是回到我们同学们的关心的问题吧
其实哪个我们课程组选了几个
同学们几个问题特别有意思
他就比如说有同学问我们说哎我们怎么看
就是这个deep learning和这个reinforcement learning的未来
就是这个深度学习和这个增强学习的未来
其实这个问题它本身呢就是怎么说呢
我觉得呃有点微妙
因为深度学习只是一种方法对吧
我猜这个同学主要问的是说诶
你是无监督的学习
还是这个有监督的学习是为了
其实这个从呃目前来讲的话呢
我觉得很多的大家都在debate
就是说比如说同样对AI大佬
比如说我们像demand的话
他其实用的还是有监督的学习多一点
那么比如像哪个就是哪个这样子OpenAI的话
它更像是这种就是增强学习多一点
那么其实这里面大家到现在还在
很多的方法都在讨论
但我个人看啊
就是说其实大家都会去想
就是我们的人类的智商
比如像我一直在思考
说什么时候
有一天我们人类真的能实现强人工智能对吧
那我觉得最好的一个类比就是我们人类自己嘛
那我们人类的学习知识
是有监督的还是无监督的呢
其实很难讲
因为大家会觉得我们人类很厉害
我们大部分时候都无监督自己去学会了
对不对
但实际上我觉得上天在我们的大脑中
其实不对应了很多东西
比如说小时候我们做错了事
我们的爸妈会对我们说啊
你这做的不对
你通过他的表情
通过他的哪个哪个不开心的脸
我们就知道我们可能做错了对吧
他很开心的
暂时我们我们就知道我们做对了
其实我觉得我们的智力是有至少在早期吧
是有很强的监督学习让我们形成的对吧
那么未来再往后的话是不是无监督学习呢
我觉得这是另外一件更有意思的事情了
比如说我们学会了下围棋呢
很多时候我们自己就会慢慢的
摸索很多的技术了
所以我觉得这件事情的话呢
呃我作为一个非常业余的
这个就是说深度学习的这个
这个业余观察者的话
我认为就是说我们很难给出判哪个判断
但我认为就是说同学们可能对这件事情
要保持一定开放性
就是很多时候大家会在想说
就是有一种心态
就是我们要押宝押
对对吧
但其实我觉得在很多时候
我们可以保持一种开放性
什么知识我们的学一点
而且呢就是其实大家看下
我们游戏引擎课有个特点是什么呢
就是实用主义
就是对于我这个specific的问题
他用哪个方法是最好最快的
能帮我解决
我就用哪个方法
就像我们上次讲讲
哪个就是哪个游戏AI这个课的时候
我们就讲的就是说虽然像deep learning啊
像哪个就是监督学习
无监督学习
其实非常的强悍
也非常的美妙
对不对
但实际上在解决很多游戏里的问题啊
有有的时候你可能用一些最基础的一些AI的
算法和工具就能解决了
所以那个时候你就不要上
不需要上那么复杂花哨的东西
对好的
那么另外一个同学也在问我们
就是说呃就是游戏的AI模块
那么就是当游戏这个就是说版本更新的时候
AI模块是不是也是要相应的剧情版本更新
那实际上的话呢就是说这个问题不一定
那因为就是首先AI确实和游戏逻辑
游戏业务深度绑定的
原则上来讲
就是说如果游戏的逻辑发生变化的话
AI有些东西需要发生变化
但实际上的话呢AI跟这个世界的连接
我们很多时候是用他的perception
就是你对世界的认知对吧
观察你对世界观察多少个变量
这些变量如果没有发生变化的话
你的决策依据其实不会发生太大的变化
除非你决定修改他的行为
那么第二个就是说
你反向的作用于这个游戏世界
就是说我能做多少种动作
如果AI体能做的还是这种70种动作
不会有变化的话
那其实游戏版本更新的时候
AI原则上其实是可以不用更新的
但是现在在现代游戏引擎中的话呢
很多时候我们的游戏的AI
比如说我们用数据或者是我们用脚本去配置好
那么实际上的话呢
这些数据和脚本它并不需要
每次游戏版本升级了
我就要更新一次对吧
除非你像我刚才讲的说
哎我对世界的这个state的表达发生了变化
或者说呢唉我能做的动作增加了或者减少了
那有些脚本可能相应的更新
那么包括如果我是用这个深度学习的方法
那假设我实质性的战场策略发生变化的时候
我这个AI系统本身也会升级
但其实呢现在的很多游戏里面啊
我们的这个游戏上线之后
我们一边会用AI指导电脑打游戏
其实一方面我也没觉得
不停的抓取真实游戏的数据
然后呢用它来training我们的那最后一个问题
就是同学问我一个
这应该是很很有趣的一个问题啊
就是哪个DLSS这个算法到底是怎么回事
首先的话呢本来我们想的高级课游戏讲的东西
但这东西其实非常的复杂
就是DRS的话
那就是deep learning super sampling对吧
那么其实就是基于深度学习的超采样
这个东西为什么很有用呢
就像我们前面讲的
就是说我们现在的rendering对吧
比如说我们一个4K屏
8K屏
那上来将近8K屏多少多少哪个像素了
应该是超过接近上亿的像素了吧
那这样大家就很郁闷了对吧
那我就一个个的渲染这个显卡都崩掉了
那DRS这个算法好处是什么呢
就是你可以用一个比如说呃
比如说720P或者1080P的东西
我能够把它upscale成4K甚至8K的画面
它的技术原理是什么呢
就是最近大家在哪个B站上特别火的一个
一类视频是什么
就是叫啊老照片
黑白照片对吧
高清还原
现在还有什么高清AI修复数字版
其实他用的都是类似的原理
就是说我其实因为人都很聪明
就是如果我找一个有经验的画师
我给你一个模糊的老照片
他可以去想象和修补
那你们他的光影和那些细节
包括人的
比如说皮肤的肌理
衣服的肌理
人的动作的细节
那这样就把这个画面修复起来了
它其实就是知识深度学习最强的一个东西
那么第二次的话呢
它实际上是对这个游戏的画面
不仅是在空间域上进行采样
就比如说你虽然像素很低诶
我从你周边的整个情况猜出来
你大概表达的是一片树叶
你大概表达的是一个人脸的皮肤
或者是一个石头的纹理对吧
或者大理石什么东西
那么也可以还要从时域上叫temporal上去采样
就是在这一帧和下一帧之间
我去找你的关联关系
其实DRS的话现在已经好像是如果没记错的话
已经是2.0了吧
就是这套算法实话实说做的是非常非常的强
就是说我们和很多哪个做rendering的朋友
去交流的时候
他们说其实第一代的算法
其实很多人都应该能够模拟出来
做出来效果差不多
但是第二代算法什么他做到了什么呢
做到了
就是说哎我已经跟特定游戏没有太大关系了
这里面就讲一下深度学习
有一个很有意思的点
就是说你把比如说我是一个花里颜色
花里胡哨的FPS游戏对吧
比如像OVERWATCH
我训练出来的这种超采样的东西
和我做一个非常写实风的
比如说哪个上古卷轴这种诶
我选出来的哪个超采算法
是不是有那么一丢丢区别呢
对吧
是完全不一样
但是呢DLSS2.0的话呢
他做到了
就几乎你不用专门为某一个特定产品
去调你的算法
这一点我说实话我也觉得非常的牛啊
我也不知道他怎么去做的
但是确实就是说啊
就是现现在深度学习的算法基于随着硬件
它本身就带了很多tensor CORE
就是那个就是那个演绎的这样的一个这个C
这些算算力在哪个在核心上就已经有了之后
实际上真的是越来越强了
所以呢这个算法的话呢
呃其实目前为止的话
最基础的算法其实有很多人在讨论
包括有些公开论文
但是最新的算法的话
目前好像还没有看到公开的资料
所以我也没办法讲太多
但是呢我们只知道说诶这个算法还挺牛逼的
包括其实全球很多的企业都在竞争这个算法
我认我个人是非常看好这个方向的
因为我认为未来的渲染的话
不应该是主像素的渲染
因为这个太慢了对吧
我认为基于DEPIN的base的算法的话
其实有很多很了不起的应用
比如现在现在特别火的
大家知道google的哪个earth做的哪个NERF对吧
这样的一个一个渲染
它能够把整个环境给你重建起来
记几张照片
这个其实也是就是人脑能做的事
也许未来这个深度学习就能做
OK好
言归正传
我这个回答我们社区的问题的部分
到此言归正传
到我们今天的课程的主体
今天课程讲什么呢
也包括接今天和接下来的两节课
我们讲什么呢
讲再online游戏这个词很难翻译啊
我这个网络游戏是不是更好一点的
叫网络游戏架构
这个一听呢在我们中国大家一讲网络游戏
大家就觉得这是个坑钱啊
或者什么什么的游戏对吧
所以哪个也叫联网游戏
我觉得嗯好像有点土对吧
那没关系吧
我们就不在这在乎这些细节
我们就叫做网络游戏的架构
那么这节课呢我们会讲一些最基础的一些概念
那么网络游戏呢
其实它是相对于单机游戏而言的
就是说其实在早期的游戏
很多时候就是你对这台电脑自己玩就可以了
对吧
玩的很开心
我们叫single player单人游戏
那么网络游戏的核心是什么呢
就是说让你在任何时候和任何人可以一起玩
就像以前我还记得小时候
我们在街机时代的时候
那我们物理的就会和别人站在一起打游戏对吧
一边打一边讨论很愉快
包括现在大家有能撑到DS的人联网的时候
也是享受这种快乐
但是呢这个不是一个终极解决方案
终极解法就是只要我有套设备
只要有网络
我就要和任何一个小伙伴能够连在一起
去一起战斗
那么其实呢就是说网络游戏
它本身呢又很挺复杂的
因为就像我们最早在最开始我在讲games co视频
就跟大家讲过
说
其实做游戏引擎
有一个我们讲的游戏引擎很复杂对吧
但其实呢他那所有的复杂
只考虑了一个人的情况
如果我们考虑两个人的情况
他这相当于什么呢
就是如果大家理解游戏引擎
是我们在做上帝的活儿
我们在模拟整个universe
整个宇宙
那么它比较麻烦的是什么呢
就是我看到的宇宙和你看到的宇宙
不是一个世界
哎这个有点像现代物理学的概念了对吧
我们讲平行宇宙
或者说这个这个客观性的言言
哪个讨论
就是说我看到的真实是不是你看到真实
这个问题在我们的游戏引擎里面
就是很这个切身的感受到了
所以我说游戏引擎的研发者
都都都会成为物理的民科啊
如果大家研究的都研究的比较深的时候
你们一定会变成哪个物理民科
就是说因为我们很深切的很直观地理解到
就是说100个人联网进入到一个虚拟世界
他们一起战斗的时候
其实他们每个人看到的世界都是不一样的
他们以为彼此看到的是同一个世界
所以说其实怎么样的
再有那么多的复杂的网络的延迟啊
信息的不完整传递的前提下
我们把这个让彼此之间的世界能够实现同步
保证我们世界之间的发生的事情是一致的
就不要在我的世界里面
这个玻璃瓶是好的
在你的世界里的玻璃瓶已经打碎了对吧
那你我看到你拿着一个碎的玻璃瓶
起来喝水的时候
我肯定知道说这个世界出了问题
上帝一定我们生活在一定的虚拟世界里面
我记得我小时候看很多电影里面讲
一个人怎么突然意识到我生活在哪个matrix
就是黑客帝国里面
就是我突然发现天空中出现了巨大的哪个
哪个什么三角形POLYG
或者说我发现了一件不可思议的事情正在发生
这就是我们生活在matrix里面的真实的证据
对不对哈
再讲下去
就是我们变成这个
哪个什么超自然科学的范畴了
那我们还是回到民科这个范畴
就是说其实啊游戏
网络游戏第一个挑战其实也是最大的挑战
就是说怎么样在那么那么多的universe里面
我们保持它的一切的事件的一致性
这件事情其实是非常的难
那么第二个难点呢
就是说其实网络世界他最恐怖的一件事情
不仅仅是延迟
而是它它的传输是不可靠的
在这个世界里面其实有很多的
比如说网络的这个这个丢包啊
或者大大面积delay或者拥塞啊对吧
甚至你会出现断线
你会重连啊
这个大家会觉得很正常
比如说你哪个网游
你觉得诶我掉线了
我回去继续能打
这不是我一个基本的需求嘛
但其实今天这节课里面我跟大家讲一下
大家就知道这件事情其实挺麻烦的
那我们以前玩过很多网友
我们可以看到
就是对方突然在做一件很逗逼的世界
比如对方突然傻在那了
动不了了对吧
我们就知道诶这哥们是不是掉线了
那么其实在我们去加一个真正的游戏
online games的这个server或者our client architecture的时候
这是我们必须要面对和思考的一个问题对吧
上帝彼此之间是不会丢包的
是不会有这个latency的
但是不好意思
在我们的游戏世界里面
我们面对的这个连接其实是经常会丢包
所以我经常讲说我有时候会羡慕上你就上帝
它是有无限的带宽对吧
而且这个不会丢包
这个还是很牛逼的一件事情
但说不定我一句话说错了
说不定如果我们真的生活在黑客帝国里面
说不定是我们的价格
是老人家解决了丢包的问题
让我们这些凡人还是感觉不到
我们生活在一个虚拟的世界好
那么第三个问题呢
其实也是在网络世界里面
大家一个共同面对的问题
就是说大家其实可能没有意识到
就是说其实online games
它本质上是一个巨大的经济系统
所以的话那么其实在online game里面的话
如何反作弊
反这个就是信息的泄露是一个很重要的责任
就大家意识到就是信我们每个用户
哪个玩家登录到游戏里面
你的个人的IP
你是个人所有的信息
包括你能不能被人家这个陌生人突然加为好友
或者是别人能hiking你的电脑
或者说去做一些作弊的行为
那么这些的话呢
其实当我们一旦做一个online game的时候
我们就要花很多时间去想这个问题
为什么呢
如果你做单机游戏对吧
你要hack我们也没有办法
我记得以前哪个啊
我玩单机游戏的时候
我经常会游戏打不过去怎么办
我可以拿一个
就是啊我忘了叫什么哪个软件叫什么来着
就是你可以找到比如说我的粮食值
或者说我的血量的这个数值
然后呢我可以把那个哪个那个内存地址找到
然后把它数值锁死
这样小怪怎么打我
我都不会掉血
然后我就可以直接强行就过关了对吧
其实它的原理非常的简单
就是你的啊
你的哪个数值
只要你看见了
你搜三次对吧
他把哪个数字都对上了
就知道是哪个数值
然后再把哪个内存地址给给给给锁死
但是对online game的话
这件事情就完全不可以接受
你怎么能接受对面来了一个人对吧
你对他一通输出
一通操作
然后对方的血动都没动
你肯定当场就摔键盘
对不对
所以说这其实是online game一个很大的一个挑战
那么第四个挑战呢其实是多样性
其实大家可能没有意识到
就是我们的online game啊
实际上它面对的设备是非常复杂的
比如说你可能是一个IPAD
可能是个IPHONE对吧
可能是android base
可能是iOS based
你可能还是PC
那对方可能还是对我们的服务器
可能是一个linux space的服务器
那这么多多样的设备
他们都要能连接在一起
而且呢都要能跑一样的逻辑
而且online game还有一个很很恐怖的一件事情
这也是啊大家在做游戏引擎的时候
很多说他意识不到的一件事情
就是说我们经常讲的一个词叫热更新对吧
其实当我们做一个online游戏出去之后
你很多时候会犯很多错误
这个没关系对吧
但是呢大家会说没关系啊
我就推个新版本
但是你想想看
当我的游戏上线之后
很多的小伙伴此时正在玩对吧
有人正在打的正嗨呢
你怎么办
你其实要有一个办法
就是让大家神不知鬼不觉的把这个bug fixed掉
你要能够快速的去迭代对吧
有的有的时候是游戏的逻辑
有些关键的游戏的一些啊
这个规则都要发生变化
那这样包括大家想象一下
就现在的网络游戏非常的复杂
大家想象一下
比如说像新世界
像最终幻想对吧
像魔兽这样的世界
它里面有多少的系统
多少的玩法
这么多东西都在这样的一个网络的一个包里面
去彼此连接
实际上的话这种多样性其实非常的恐怖
所以这也是online
我们在做这个就online gaming的时候很头疼的一个问题
但确实你要去面对的一个问题
那么最后一个的话呢
也就是真正的复杂度吧
比如说如果我们要构建一个
像头号玩家里的绿洲这样的世界的话
大家想想看
我们要上万的人对吧
在同一个世界里一起去战斗
打枪的打枪拿刀
这个砍小怪的砍小怪
那么这么高的并发度
其实你会发现啊
就是如果我先两个人在一起连接的
这个操作其实还比较简单
但是我一旦变成了两两百个人对吧
变成了2000个人
变成了2万个人的话
它的复杂度是以N平方在急剧扩张的
而且这里面的话呢
实际上这些人的网络链接会越来越复杂
所以其实像这种的复杂度的话
实际上是现代哪个online gaming的话
一个非常有挑战的一个价格问题
但我不知道这节课我们有没有时间
本来我们计划有有有计划
先讲一下这个这个这种架构
但是呢等我们PPT准备完之后
发现我们第一节课就讲了200页
准备了200页的PPT的时候
我们想嗯我们第二节课再看吧对吧
那我们啊
所以呢这是但确实我我想就是所有有兴趣学games
104的同学的话应该要知道
就是这其实是啊下一代游戏引擎很质
很重要的一个挑战
就是我们觉得这是未来世界
我们一直梦想的那样一个
games世界的一个一个一个一种起源
我已经受够了
让我进到一个小房间里面
和几个小伙伴在一起的
这个只能你看着我看你的世界
我希望真的有一个让无限进无限出啊
我看到无数的人在一起的那样的一个虚拟世界
这是我的职业梦想吧
好所以说其实这就通过这几点
我相信同学们就有感觉了
就说诶其实online game还是蛮挑战的
那么好
那今天的话呢
我们就开始了我们online game的第一节课
这节课呢我们会告诉大家一些最基本的东西
比如说最基础的网络协议是什么
大家会觉得诶
这一趴是不是要教我
这个最基础的叫计算机网络基础啊
大家在大学的时候
有没有学过这么厚的一本
叫计算机网络基础对吧
那有可能我们会有些内容跟那里面去重的
但确实你会发现当你要做网络游戏的时候
不好意思
大学的时候可以逃课对吧
可以这个这个作业找别人代写
但是你到了自己一些引擎的时候
那些基础的知识该复习的还是要复习的
那么接下来我给大家讲一些很基本的一些概念
比如时钟怎么去对齐对吧
比如说RPC到底是个什么东西
包括我要做一个网络游戏
我网络拓扑结构到底应该下成什么样子
那最后呢会给大家讲几个最主流的
就是说网络哪个游戏同步的机制
比如说从快照同步啊
到这个真同步啊
到这个就是状态同步啊对吧
这些都是最basic的
然后呢下一节课会给大家讲一些有意思的东西
那就是比如说哎听了这么多
其实一个角色在网络环境里面
它的移动怎么同步
大家其实并不知道对吧
这个听上去有点让人沮丧啊
比如说我一个射击打中了
到底没打中
怎么去对齐这件事
也其实大家并不知道网络有波动的时候
我怎么去补偿对吧
包括一个标准的一个M游戏的网络服务器架构
该怎么去架构
当然了
还有一些更详细的一些概念
比如AI啊
怎么去反作弊
当然了
也许我们有时间
还可以提一些更有趣的一些东西
所以我们每节课都是这样
就准备之前每节课准备的时间
我们都会觉得哇操这个时间
这个这个这个这个讲啥呢
哪有那么多好讲
当我们开始真的下手去准备的时候
总发现课程这个时间不够
那么今天的话呢
我们就啊
先把最基础的概念跟同学们讲清楚对吧
这个基础概念也是好像是今天的课程
好像也是一百一百四十页左右吧
但是我争取不要再创造哪个三个小时的记录了
OK好那我们先给大家讲这个网络的基础的协议
诶
这个很有意思啊
就是说其实首先的话呢
我们传统的节目就要拜神对吧
我们要确实要拜我们的两位大神
就是说是他们最早这个winter和哪个ROBERT
他们最早去创立的
这个我们的哪个互联网的概念
然后呢他发明了TCPIP协议
人家很厉害
人家一上来就能实现
就是实验室通过电话线
通过卫星的这个所有的链接
当然这是美国军方的一个项目
所以有的时候我们不得不承认
就是说唉
军事总是能推推进人类科技的发展对吧
那么其实你会说
就有的时候你当我们去研究下去
TCBAP协议的时候
我们还真的很佩服老人家
就是很早就能够把这几个概念呢分得那么清楚
然后呢
能够让我们能够在上面能很轻松的去做
我们的开发
所以说这确实是我这个就是整个前任
哪个什么前人挖井
后人吃水吧
我们就享受这种快乐
那么其实的话呢它核心解决的问题是什么呢
就是说我们如何在两台电脑之间传递数据
那么首先的话大家想想
两台电脑之间物理传输是不是特别的粗暴
比如说到底几幅算零
几幅算一呢对吧
我传了0101出去之后
哪个算偷
哪个算伪呢
对不对
然后的话呢就是这个这些所有的这些信息的话
实际上如果没有这些political的话
实际上我们没有办法穿的
那这个时候呢其实我们就会发现
就是说当我的协议站是很复杂的
我的硬件连接也是非常有
又有同城电缆电缆对吧
又有无线路由器
又有哪个就是网线光纤
那其实这里面
如果我们不做一个特殊的处理的话
你会发现我们要处理很多很多很奇怪的情况
但是呢
同学们如果自己去学一些简单的T和电脑知识
我们知道说哎很多事情不需要我们去发愁了
因为我们在中间加了一层中间的layer
这层layer的话
其实把所有的硬件的这种复杂性全部隔绝掉
所以大家各种协议
只是直接往里面去写东西对吧
然后呢由他们来负责各种分发
大家如果有机会啊
去到哪个机房去啊
我我我因为我工作的原因嘛
我经常去机房嘛
我每次对我们的IT的同学就特别的崇拜
因为你当你看到哪个一个一个路由器
就真正专业级的路由器
那分出来那些线的时候
你会觉得我的天呐
就是跟大家讲一下
就机房里面盘哪个电缆线的
哪个就是哪个哪个cable的
哪个人都是一门技术活
它11cm的线都要有编号
然后接上这么粗的这个电缆柱
这样走起来很足的电缆线
所以说你会发现在这里面无数的比特在交换
无数的比特在算法
但是呢
今天当我们去写一个网络的这个程序的时候
我们其实根本不需要去在乎这样的一些复杂度
对吧
这就是要感谢我们的前任
把这个分成分的非常好
所以这里面的话呢就是要感谢一下我们的前人
著名的OSI模型
对不对
那么其实这个模型的话呢
就是我们最经典的这个网络的七层模型
一层一层的下来
那看了那么多
对不对
从最最基础的physics层到哪个数据连接层
到网络层
到这个传输层对吧
到网上绘画层
到我们的这个就是表达层和我们的应用层
实际上我们一般用不到那么深
我们大概一般都在应用层
各种鬼混就完事了
然后呢接下来就往上传数据
但是这种分层结构这种思想其实非常的有用
而且我待会儿后面还跟他讲的
就是我们在定义很多协议的时候
其实我们需要对这东西有一些基础的理解
比如说为什么这件事情很重要
举个例子
比如说你要做一个应用
假设你做一个啊
比如说啊哪个
比如说CDN对吧
就是一个给人家提供各种下载服务的东西
你需要对着七层协议非常理解
那么你会发现
这七层里面有大量的冗余的数据拷贝
对不对
你可以直接对这个协议底层进行优化对吧
那这当然这是一些非常高端的一些东西了
那么在往我们做游戏的时候呢
有的时候我们不用那么深
但是不代表
在未来最前沿的一些产品研发的时候
我们有可能对这个协议都要进行优化好
那么其实呢
对于大部分的这个游戏引擎开发者来讲的话
我们不需要那么复杂
我们说OK我们用一个socket编程
对吧
socket多方便
对不对
你只要提供一个IP地址
提供一个就是说哪个port端口号
我就可以跟对方建立我想要的链接了
但其实你们仔细看所有的网游
它本质上你下载好你的客户端
你怎么去找到人家的服务器呢
实际上是在客户端你就写死了
说你就到这个IP地址
你就到哪个port已经在连到我的服务器
当然了
这里面没有那么简单
因为如果就是那么简单的话
比如说我用最简单的一个DDOS攻击
就可以把一个游戏给黑掉
但其实呢大家在网络游戏啊
以前至少最怕的一个东西是什么
就是被别人恶意攻击
就是啊因为有你
因为你的服务器地址必须必须是开放的嘛
如果他本身不具有一定的
就是说这个这个抗DDOS的能力的话
其实你可以很容易地写一个东西
把一个比如说别人在运行的好好的游戏
给他攻击掉
但现代网游的话呢
一般会做了很多的相应的处理
就是没有那么简单了
同学们标示啊
这个是违法的
好不好
哈哈这个所有这个你觉得有趣的事情
很可能就是旁边就是有东西在等着你
所以我只是跟大家讲一个这样的一个
技术原理啊
这个不好意思
教小朋友学坏了啊
然后呢
其实socket的话呢本身也是比较简单
很明确的对吧
就是说它实际上就是说
你通过这样的一个简单的接口
你就可以跟另外一台机器间的连接
然后呢你确定好你的协议
就可以持续不断的往对方去传输你这样的东西
那这里面的话
我想给大家分享一个很有意思的东西
就是说其实在socket建立的时候
大家会说哎我是到底是IPV4
IPV6对吧
我到底走的是TCB还是UTB协议
对这些东西大家的标准哪个选项
我这边讲有意思的东西
就是我们在中国
我们做很多在线应用的时候
我们一般用的是IPV4G多一点
当然大家如果注意到
就是如果你要做一个真正的通用游戏引擎的话
我会建议大家一定要考虑IPV6
因为什么呢
因为在全球有很多国家
我如果没记错的话
好像是德国吧
我记得德国就是其中一个
就是他们已经大面积的在使用IPV6了
所以你你的做了一个服务器的话
如果你不进入FPV6的话
有可能很多用户连接不上你的服务器
所以说你要做一个提供服务器的游戏
引擎的时候
A不好意思
这就是你要考虑的内容了
对吧好
那么其实这里面的话
当我们有了socket之后
我们就要理解什么叫大名鼎鼎的游戏了啊
有那个哪个哪个pole了
就协议了
那最著名的就是TCP协议了
TCP协议其实是一个最最经典的一个
互联网的协议
可以说互联网上传递的绝大部分信息的话
其实都通过TCP来去传输
大家怎么去理解TCP协议呢
就具体的细节我就不展开了对吧
那么TCP协议呢它首先是一个就是通过三次握手
建立了一个牢靠的这样的一个连接
所以TCP连接是一个比较稳的
那么另外一个的话呢
就是说它的确保我的发的包一个一个一次一次
它是有顺序的
就是前面的包不会和后面的包去冲突
另外一个呢TCP呢还有一个很厉害的属性
就是什么呢
它会进行流量控制
也就是说当网络发生拥塞啊
或者各种阻塞的时候
它会自动的降低我发布的效率
所以说这也是为什么很多啊
比如说网关配的策略的时候
对TCP都相对比较友好
如果这个是这个就这么说吧
如果互联网上跑的都不是TCP协议的话
很可能今天我们大家用的网络都是非常的这个
拥塞不堪
因为每一个人都是玩着命的给别人发消息对吧
就跟我们讲这个
比如大家每个人都是玩命的发电邮
反正呢也不用管你
邮票也不花钱
结果你很容易就会把这个就是说这个一个邮
邮件服务器给轰炸掉对吧
以前我们知道有垃圾邮件
其实TCB这一点的话
它其实是有流量控制的
说如果每天这个网
我们的网络上下行链路传输的量
超过了我的上限的时候
我会相相应的进行一些控制
那么PCB的包头呢比较长了
它可以达到20个BT
就20个字节那么大
其实还是有点有点有点有点重的
但是的话呢它一旦建立链接之后呢
它就会持续不断地传传这个信息
那么它能够保证这个信息的一致性
其实TCB啊
它的核心原理实际上就是一个叫rich Mission
Mechanism
就是非常的简单
就是这里面它实际上就当我的任何一个接收者
收到一个信息的时候
诶我给我的3DER发一个ACOLOGMENT的
就是一个告知
就A4简称ACK
那么我的center呢只有收到了ACK之后
我在持续的网上发报
当然这是最基本的原理啊
其实在后面我们会讲到一些更多的细节
但是大家知道这个基本原理就可以了
就是说如果我却没有得到确认
说我的内容被你收到之后
那我就会持续给你发对吧
这个当然了
这个本身也会导致一些网络拥塞
那另外一个的话呢
就是说其实TCP呢它有一个很有趣的叫做
这个就是拥塞控制
它
实际上就刚才刚才
大家看到我们塞的这么多包啊
它不是真的一个一个散
它是一次一次一批批散的
它是有个有个窗口的
但是呢他一开始窗口很小
然后呢我就开始传传传
如果我每次都很顺利传过去
很快我就收到别人的ACLACK
就ACCLASSMAN的话呢
我说ok fine
那我就把我的窗口变得更大一点
我就一次性多传一些对吧
但是呢当我一旦发现我的这个ACCLASSM的
这个包出现丢包的时候
哎我就开始把我的哪个窗口往下滑
就我一次就少散的一点
这样的话当我们去大家想象一下
如果在一个不是特别稳定的网络环境下
比如说有可能是因为网络真的有丢包了
或者说他只是因为波动对吧
大家知道网络其实是会经常波动的
为什么呢
大家想想看你们家小区的网络
当你们家小区现在有部很火的这个电影
哪个比如说大电影网络网
大电影上线的时候
你会发现你们小区的网络就一定很差
为什么大家所有人都在抢哪个贷款
那么同样在一个不稳定的一个公网上的情况下
其实TCB的链接给你看到的整个带宽的波动
就像这张图这样
就是诶一会儿快
一会儿慢
一会儿快
所以当我们做一些应用的时候
特别是对游戏这种对时间特别敏感的时候
我们就会觉得有点难受对吧
这是但是呢它实际上也是TCP
很多时候导致大家的延迟的一个原因
但同时又是我们互联网上就是能够保证
就是互联网没有炸掉的一个很大的一个保障
因为美如果每个人都遵守这个TCP协议的话
实际上我们有一个动态的
就相当于就像就像马路上开车
你发现哪个这个车前面车很多的时候
你可以自觉地把速度减慢对吧
你会自觉的不去挤上哪个高架
那个高架最终还是能通行的
如果所有人都不管不顾的往上冲的话
那高架很快就堵牢了
堵牢了之后
大家全都走不了
所以说这我我要讲的就是TCB的这个
congestion control的环
实际上对互联网是落立功了了
但这件事情的话呢
唉为什么在讲一个游戏引擎课上
会讲的那么那么细呢
因为这东西跟我们的关系还是蛮大的
好
另外一个的话呢就是要讲到这个TCP的问题的话
就要讲到另外一个大名鼎鼎的协议了
就UDP了对吧
UDP哪个老哥其实非常有意思
其实他实际上也是TCP的发明者之一
但是他在10年之后吧
就发明了这个就是UDP这个协议
它本质上哪个端端端的协议
大家想想TCP也很万能对吧
它能够在整个哪个互联网上去广播啊
去找东西
但是呢UDP他的想法很单纯
就是如果我只有两个设备
我们彼此之间传数据怎么传
那我肯定希望越简单越好
对不对
我也不要那么多复杂的哪个约束了对吧
我也不要求你的order有什么东西
那么其实呢
所以这个老哥就发明了UDP这个协议
其实UDP这个协议呢
其实我个人还是蛮非常喜欢的
就是说第一个呢
他就是说不需要建立长时间的链接
就是我们不要没事握手对吧
我看你顺眼
我就直接发给你了
你爱收不收
那是你的事对吧
第二个的话呢
就是A我其实也不是要求你一定要稳定
然后呢也不要求你保证一定order
就像你发电影一样的
我我你这个邮件早收到这个几分钟
晚收到几分钟也死不了人对吧
那我就不停的这个发
我就发给你就行了
第二个的话呢
我没有这个flow control
也没有这个congestion control
就是流量控制
我也不管
这就是UTP
实际上是个很祸害的一个一个一个协议
就是说呃怎么说呢
就是如果你想用UDP干坏事的话
UDP其实很容易干坏事
就是他反正也没有流量控制
你就往上塞就好了
那么因为他的协议非常的简单啊
所以UDP它的包头就会比较的轻
如果我没记错
应该只有四个字
四个BT
就是说四个字节32位
我就能存一个UTB的包头
这样看看是不是诶
我的包头就比TCP轻了五倍左右
所以这是UDP一个很大的一个优势
那么好
那所以呢其实呢在现代游戏里面
你可以发现就是说不同的游戏他的选择不同
比如说你看像哪个我们的炉石选用的就是TCP
对吧
打打打炉石用于TCP
然后呢比如像守望啊
像其他的游戏
我们用的是什么呢
我们用的是TCUDP
但实际上呢这两个协议诶真真实的
在游戏中的话
举个例子啊
比如说一个大型的MV里面
我们到底选哪个呢
这里面我只能分享一下我个人的一些经验
我们没有不一定按照这个课件去读
给他他课件的东西
大家可以读一读
这些话说的也是有道理的
但是的话呢实际上我的理解就是说
比如像你打炉石这种对吧
你对延迟
比如说0.2秒
0.3秒
你真的那么介意吗
好像没有
那么介意对吧
对于那种时间并没有那么特别敏感的操作
我们会选择用TCP协议比较好一点对吧
它它连接是稳定的
那么但是的话呢
对于比如说快速的这种射击游戏啊
我要响应特别特别快啊
尤其是在这种不稳定的网络的情况下
特别公网上的话
其实大家现在越来越多的会有UTB这个协议
因为它是非常responsive的
反应比较快
但是真正的对一个大型的
就是这个这个这个mo来讲的话
实际上它用的一般都不是单一的协议
他会用组合协议
比如说我有的时候用TCP协议来进行签名认证
确定你的登录啊
建立你的账号链接啊
而且这个这个有的时候我们心跳也会用
就是哪个心跳包也会用TCP一直给你维持住
但有的时候我们也用UDP
但是呢游戏真的战斗啊
进入到这个世界的时候
我又会UDP
但是呢说不定我到了聊聊天啊
我到了那个什么别的
比如说邮件啊
我可能又走了哪个TCB的通道
其实我们一般会看哪个通道更合适
我就走哪个通道
所以简单来讲的话呢
就是这个又回到了我们104的这个精神
就是说游戏引擎
实际上它是一个没有任何的教条主义的这样
一个一个一个工程科学
所以一切的一切的这个
这个就是说人类智慧的成果
对我们来讲都是工具
我们更重要的是要构建那样的一个黑客帝国
这样的世界
所以的话呢对每个技术
我们都要有一个比较清晰的定位和理解好
这就是一个最基本的哪个网络的协议
哎如果故事讲到这儿
我们就结束了对吧
大家知道了TCPUDB
那我们就凭着自己的感觉去用吧
但实际上的话呢在现代游戏里面
我们很多时候并不会直接的用原生态的引擎
我们会对啊
原生态的这个就是说协议
我们会对协议进行改造
那么这个为什么要改造呢
其实这个问题其实在前面已经讲的比较清楚了
就是大家没有发现就TCP的问题是什么
哎呀这个老人家磨磨磨唧唧的对吧
它非常的好
很很很稳健
很可靠
但是呢它的带宽一会儿上一会儿下对吧
而且呢前面的消息只要没有收到确认
后面的消息似乎不发
其实有的时候打游戏的时候
你有的时候有些消息丢了不就丢了嘛
无所谓
对不对
我我现在我这个输出
我这个操作我就特别想打出去对吧
我一通操作
把对方就想这个直接给哪个血给磨没了
对不对
你这时候不让我发出去
就是因为我前面一个移动这个消息没有传过去
那我觉得作为玩家是不是很难受对吧
那那肯定TCB
这个时候大家就会觉得有点难受了
那怎么办呢
哎我们用UDPUT意识很好
他非常fast
而且它能满足我的要求
就是今天我打出了一个输出
我前面一个向左移动
我一个连跳没传过去
拉倒无所谓对吧
但是的话UDP实际上是真的是非常的不reliable
也是某种意义上来讲的话
我们根本不知道这老哥到底有没有传到
对吧
那那这个问题就比较麻烦了
对不对
你发出去的包
这个这个这个打出去就不管了
对不对
那我服务器客户端之间最起码的信任都会没有
所以其实这个时候就会有聪明人说哎
我能不能把两个学期的优点给结合起来
这其实就是在现代游戏引擎里面
就是这也是我会推荐大家
如果你们在做自己的游戏引擎
特别是做online联名的时候
我会非常推荐大家
就是要么去采用第三方的
让我们自己定制一个啊
基于UDP的一个可靠链接的协议
这件事情其实啊难度并不像大家想的那么大
而且这里面的很多很有趣的一些数学原理
大家也可以在里面去自己应用
所以呢这就是我们104课要讲的就是
A如何构建一个可靠的UDP连接
那么就是说这里面的话呢
其实前面已经讲的比较清楚了
就是说为什么定制一个自己定这个协议
这么重要的
其实我们去看哪个游戏的服务器开发
和网络的服务器
就是标准的web服器开发其实有很大的区别
游戏你会发现
比如说我们要总是要保持活着的链接
这个看听上去有点像TCP对吧
然后呢
我们最好呢要保证这些消息传递
还是有一定order的
我们真的乱序
其实我们也受不了对吧
我们有些动作
比如说我要先给自己喝个草药对吧
然后我的我的我的这个这个魔法之上了
然后我再去打一个技能对吧
我的魔魔法就够了
我的蓝够了
那这个还是有顺序的
对不对
那么所以呢我们还是要保持一定的这个order
在里面
这两个需求听上去好像挺7CP的对吧
但是的话呢我们又要非常高的
这个就是responsive
非常快
而且最好没有延迟
还有一个的话呢就是经常我们要群发对吧
就像我们讲了
这个上帝如何能够实现多个宇宙
multiverse之间的信息同步
是不是我经常要send all对吧
就是这个服务器说收到一件事
我马上就要send or send send
所以我经常有broadcasting这样的需求
那么其实这两个呢其实又很符合UDB的特征
所以呢我们就很贪心地说
我们能不能定制一个协议
把这两大协议的这个优点都结合在一起
那么实际上的话这里面先讲一个基本的概念
就是说哪个前面其实前面已经提到了
OLOGAN的ACK对吧
就是说我收到一个包
我给你确认收收过了
其实ACK呢还有一个他的孪生兄弟
叫n AC k neck
就是说negative AC k什么意思呢
就是说我除了能告诉你说
我收到了某某的包之外
我还能告诉你说哎什么包我没收到对吧
那这样的话是不是一样也有信息量传递下来
其实你会发现做网络很多时候
我觉得跟信息学的一些技术理论很接近
就是我们在一个彼此不可靠的链接下
怎么样建立一个可靠的彼此信任的通讯
它本质还是这么个原理
其实我们在人类古代大家想想看啊
因为我以前很喜欢读历史嘛
就很有意思
你会发现古代
比如说A地到BD两个指挥官之间
他们要协同作战
但是他们知道我传递的所有的这个传信的
这样的一个通讯者
他们都有可能会半路上被人截杀对吧
而且也有可能被人compromise
就是被人俘获并且叛变
然后呢
而且呢这个中间会有个latency
就有很多的延迟
对不对对吧
那么好
那怎么样的
在两支协同作战的军队之间
建立这种可靠的通讯
其实也是一个非常有意思的一个问题
这个问题其实跟我们在网络的问题上
解决的问题一模一样
那么另外一个的话呢
就是我们要加入这个序列号
那这个其实大家知道
我给哪个包哪个编号对吧
那么呢还有一个time out
就是说诶过期的时间就有些时间时间过长了
我们就不理他了
其实当我们去基于UDP
构建一个相对稳定的这样的链接的时候呢
你又要用到这些概念
这些概念呢实际上啊你说他陌生吗
他其实不陌生
大家如果去学习TCP的真正的底层实现的时候
你会发现这些就是我们的老朋友对吧
那首先的话呢这里面的话要提出一个概念
就是这个ARQ对吧
就是说自动的这个回复的这个哪个重复的要求
它实际上是个简单的例子
就是说当我建立一个就是网络链接传播的时候
如果我丢包了
或者我没有收到的时候
我能够有个方法能告诉你
你能自动给我传发包
所以我所有的算法都要实现LRQ这样的效果
那LUQ呢有很多算法
所以呢我们在这里跟大家简单讲几个基础
基础概念
那么第一种概念呢
就是说哎我们要有一个叫sliding window pole
就是滑动窗口协议
就是说当我的包体啊
一大块很多很多的数据我要传输的时候
其实我有个窗口的
我一次性会把窗口你的数据全传过去
这个时候当我收到了诶
是那个接收方发返回来的ACK包的时候
比如说我收到了第2号包回来的时候
我就知道了
哪个345就是3号包啊
哪个2012已经传传输出到位了
因为我只要顺序的确认嘛
那我接下来就把3456传过去
那因为三我已经传了
我就把456传传过去对吧
直到我收到了后续的这个ACK这个包
过来之后
我这个窗口游戏需求也往下滑
这个原理是不是非常的简单对吧
那么这里面的话呢我们就有很多策略了
比如说最简单stop and the weight a r q
什么意思呢
就是说我这个窗口是三零
我每个包放完之后
我都在都要等你的这个确认了
包收到
我再往上走
那这个的话呢
这个方法其实是最古典的一个方法
这个方法从来就没有用过
为什么呢
因为它特别笨
你想想看
比如说我有很多的上行带宽对吧
但是呢我传完一个包
传完之后
我就等等等
网络的延迟至少一个来一来一回的话
一两百毫秒至少过去对吧
那这一两百毫秒的话
我们所有人都在等着呢
所以这个带宽其实没有被充分的利用
所以呢这个呢是一个最简单的方法
那么还有一个就是go back and aq
什么意思
就是其实刚才那个窗口里面
就是说如果我发现我一个包丢了之后
我其实只是把一个窗口
你的包再重新传一遍
那这个的话呢
策略呢其实是一个非常实用的一个策略
实际上在我们的这个就是
如果我们做自己的reliable
这个UDP的协议的时候
诶
我会推荐大家用这个策略
那么更有意思的就是selective repeat a r q
这个地方的话
其实它是用了哪个negative l q l ark
就是说我告诉你是说什么包我没有收到
你就继续往下传
但是我告诉你说
比如说我哪个包我丢了
比如在这里面的话
2号包丢了
那好那你把2号包再给我再传一次就好了
那这样的话呢其实它的链接可以更稳定
而且呢也能节约一些不必要
不必要的哪个贷款的浪费
但是他有个额外的那个就是哪个a logy的类型
就是NARK
就是告诉你说这个包我没有收到
这里的算法讲讲起来的细节其实是非常的多
但这个呢不是我们这节课的重点
其实我我想跟大家讲的
就是说
同学们如果要去构建一个自己的
就是for游戏引擎的这样的一个网络
底层的时候呢
确实要非常认真的去考虑
你下面要构建一层
基于UDP的一个可靠的网络连接
但这种东西的话
其实现在啊有很多的开源库
也在解决类似的问题
就是说他能够就UTB给你构建一个唉
你要保证顺序一致啊
你要保证这个非常可靠啊
你要保证哪个非常低延迟啊
这样的一个一个一个一个包装
所以我觉得UDP是个很好的协议
就是它提供了一个很基础的构建模块
上面的策略完全用我们自己去配置
那么其实的话呢就是说还有一点就是说诶
其实在UTP传输的时候呢
我们还经常会遇到一个问题
就是丢包对吧
UTP说了丢包我不管对吧
我只管发出去
但是他可以不管
我们得管
那这个怎么办
诶
这里面有一个很重要的策略
就是这个forward error correction
这这个策略的话呢
也是我们在构建的底层会用到的东西
就是说如果你丢包了之后
我能不能说在丢包率
比如说只有5%啊
10%的时候
我不要没事就让你重传一遍
大家知道重传这个事情很麻烦对吧
我第一个我要等你的ACK收到
收到之后呢
我然后再把那个老早以前的包拿来
给你重传一遍
而且如果是一个滑动窗口的方式
其实我后面的所有的包都得卡在那儿
对不对
所以说其实如果有一个方式是说你的包丢了
我也不管我继续往前走的话
那是不是岂不美哉
所以的话呢
其实聪明的人类就想出了很多方法说诶
我能不能有一个方法
就是说我收到了包
我知道这个数据丢了
但是我一样能够把你正确的数据给找到
这里面的话呢就有一个非常有意思的策略了
我们叫做
我们以前在学这个计算机体系结构的时候
经常讲的一句话
叫什么叫空间换时间对吧
那我我就是用额外的数据传输量
来解决这个问题
那大家说怎么办
我把数据再传一遍
对不对
我哪个数据传两遍行不行啊
当然可以了
但这个方法实在太笨了对吧
我们还是要用一点稍微高级的方法
其实呢这个其实是VC
这个这个算法就是for的哪个哪个error correction
哪个算法实际上比大家想象的要简单
这里面我给大家介绍两种很简单的算法
第一种方法就是什么呢
抑或降盐味的算法对吧
第二种呢就算哪个介绍哪个啊
就是SOLOMON的一个算法
Solomon codec
这也是计算机信息里面最经典的一个算法吧
OK那首先讲异或吧
抑或其实大家知道什么叫异或运算
对不对
就是说当给你两个beat
那么他们如果是一样的话
那么它的异或值就是零
就表示你们俩一通我不喜欢对吧
你们两个是不一样
比如说A是零
B是一
或者是A是一
B是零
他们两个就是哪个异或运算结果就是一对吧
如果两边都是一异或运算
120这个算法提上去哎
就那么回事
对不对
好像我们在学计算机组成原理的时候
我们经常会用到这个这个算法
那异或运算它巧妙在什么地方呢
哎大家看看我们这里哪个有意思的东西
就是当我给你数据
假设有ABCD4个数据
我把ABCD的异化算出来的结果是E的话
你得到了这个值呢
其实就是一个校验位
这个校验位呢不仅可以校验你这个值
对不对
他其实也不算校验嘛
但是他其实确实可以教研
但是他更厉害的是什么呢
就是当你的ABCD中间任何一个丢掉的话
我可以把你的剩下的地方
和我的E在一起做异或运算
得到的结果就是你原来的值
哎这个数学让大家可以自己推演一下
其实很简单
但是呢这个定理是可以被证明的
他一定对的
但是大家会问说
那如果E自己被丢了怎么办
那也无所谓了
反正我的信息是ABCD嘛对吧
E丢了就丢了
拉倒了这个东西其实是什么呢
就是大家哪个如果学过哪个硬盘的
存储阵列的时候
大家知道有个概念叫red five
对不对
就是哪个rate对吧
就是我们的存储
哪个磁盘存储的哪个数据的冗余
其实就是这个算法对吧
就是我五块硬盘
四块硬盘存数据
一块硬盘存它的异或值
这样的话这四块里面其实五块里面坏了
任何一个哎
我都能迅速的把这个数据pick up对吧
这其实就是这个道理
所以其实这个简单的原理的话呢
就可以用在我们的计算机里面
所以这里面大家可以算个概率
就是说如果我的丢包率大概只有12%
或者是5%的时候
其实你这个预算在这的话
你可以极大的减少
你的这个就是重发的这个概率
但是如果你的丢包率接近于10%
到20的时候
诶
你会发现哎呀你又浪费了我20%的贷款
其实很多时候你还是救不了我的命对吧
但这里面要有一个比较严格的一个概率运算了
这里面我就不展开了
那么这个方法呢其实还是挺不错的
那有没有就是说诶我可以同时丢两个数据
甚至更多的数据我都不会丢掉的
算法呢
这里面的话就要讲著名的这个RESOLOMON的这个
codex算法
这个其实是一个计算机的哪个高级
哪个就是体系结构里面一个很重要的一个算法
这个算法其实不止用在我们的网络重输
他的简单
他的思想其实是非常的巧妙
就是说我对于我任何一个codex的信息
比如说D我去构建一个
就是说哪个王尔蒙德的这个这个这个矩阵
这个矩阵的特点是什么呢
就是说我的上半部分是一个对角阵对吧
全是一下半部分呢
这个是我构造出来的哪个矩阵
它的特点是什么呢
就是说我从中间的任何任意抽调
比如说若干行
这13行哎
比如说我我玩玩延拖了三行
我中间任意抽到三行
这个矩阵都是可逆的
那这个可逆性为什么这么重要呢
大家看这个情况啊
比如说我现在把这个矩阵构建好了之后
比如说我构建了一个矩阵叫B
然后呢我把这个信息D跟这个B进行一个乘法
那我得到了我这个我codex出来的这个信息记
大家发现没有
记得上部分跟原来的数据是一模一样的对
但下部分好像出现了一些荣誉的信息
比如说我现在呃五个信息里面我加了三个荣誉
对吧
好
这个时候假设我非常不幸的在传输的过程中
我丢了大概啊123
我丢了三个包对吧
这是最最坏的情况
就是啊我八个包中我丢了三个
这个丢包率接近于百分之
应该就快要接近30%了吧
哦不止了
30%到35%左右了
好这种情况下
我能不能把信息给它恢复
大家看这个时候呢
你会发现这个矩阵运算是这样的
就是实际上你把你所有丢掉的哪个信息的哪个
哪个哪个哪个那行啊
那那应该是那一行对
把它全部移掉
你就可以从B矩阵收缩成B1撇矩阵
而且这个BP矩阵的话呢
它一定是一个就是一个一个一个一个一个
就是长宽一样的这个矩阵
然后呢他实际上你现在得到了质量
不是相当于说B1撇乘上了原始信息
然后得到了你现在拿到这个信息吗
那这里面就有一个非常简单的一个数学变化了
就是说如果这件事情成立的话
我把B1撇给他求个逆对吧
那我让他去乘上这个我拿到的这个信息的话
其实它就等于这个
我就等于说把原来的数据给重建出来了
这里面其实本质上原因是什么呢
就是这个矩阵呢它本身你任意抽调三行
它都能够得到一个可逆的矩阵
所以呢它这就意味着什么
意味着你的信息其实是没有丢掉的
所以你通过一部数学的逆运算
就可以把原来的信息给重建出来
所以这个算法的话呢
实际上是一个非常啊无proven
就是已经被证明了非常好的一个算法
而且实际上在网络传输中
我们用的其实非常多
包括就是如果大家想建议
建立一个鲁棒的这种网络链接
打个比方吧
比如说你大家做的是手游对吧
那么在手游的话
移动端下的话
这个网络链接其实很多时候都是不稳定的
那么用这个RESOLOMON的这个算法的话呢
实际上是能够非常好的帮助你解决丢包的问题
因为有的时候在手机上丢包率
甚至可以超过10%到20都有可能
因为你家里加了又有WIFI
又是手游对吧
这个就很麻烦
所以的话呢我们不能老是要断线重连
老是在等新的包
因为我每一次等于他的ACK的话
200ms就过去了
那其实这个游戏就没法玩了
所以说这个东西其实不是
大家会觉得这里面数学是不是很抽象
其实数学非常的简单
就是你构造一个矩阵
中间任意抽掉他的哪个哪个若干行之后
诶
他还是一个可逆的矩阵
这样的话我拿到的信息之后
只要乘上哪个抽掉对应行的哪个矩阵的逆
我就可以把原始的信心恢复了
其实就这么个简单的道理
但是的话呢它实际上真的是非常的有用
所以其实啊今天我们讲
就是说
我们要构建一个自己的可靠的基础链接的话
实际上我个人的理解就是
你只要对OORQ的基本算法有所理解对吧
你可以选择性的使用说诶
我用这个就是哪个slide windows的方法
去一个PO去传输我的数据对吧
我确定我的这个就是说resin的策略
RETRANSMIT的策略
其实RETR视频策略其实完全可以
自己很多的小小技巧可以去定制
然后呢我再加上一定的FEQ的这个算法
这样保证即使在一定的丢包率的情况下
我这个包体还是能正确的收到
这样的确保我的ACK的话总是成功
尽量的成功
不要老是丢掉
那么当这两个东西在自由组合的时候
其实啊你就可以定制自己的独立的UTB策略
所以大家会发现
就是说在很多的游戏引擎底层的网络链接
假设它是用UDP包装过的话
它一般当你建立链接的时候
一般我们会建立很多链接
就是说我们的客户端和服务器
会建立各种各样的链接
然后呢诶你可以选择策略
比如有些东西我就是要求他高稳定性对吧
但我对延迟并不是那么敏感
那我可能诶策略中会向稳定性那边切清
哪个轻的更多一点
这个地方的话呢
其实我要求的是low latency
就是我要响应特别快
但是丢几个包问题不大
比如说玩家那种左移右移的那种操作对吧
丢了两个也无所谓
对不对
那没关系
那我就可以追求哪个
就是说highly response对吧
对于这种就是说他的哪个就是丢包啊
这些东西我并没有那么敏感
所以其实这就意味着
就是说当我们把这个没有用包装好的TCP协议
而是要用自己的UDP自己去组合的时候
你会发现特别适合游戏的这种复杂的情况
我可以自由组合各种我们想要的这种体验对吧
这个定制化DIY总是开开心的
所以讲了这么多
其实跟大家讲的就是
我们作为一个网游的最基础的东西
首先你怎么建立一个网络链接
大家发现没意思
就是说作为一个引擎
连底层的链
底层的哪个传输协议都需要我们自己定义定制
确实是这样
如果大家如果做一些更复杂的这个
这个网络游戏的话
甚至有可能哪个连底层的协议账我们都要去改
当然哪个就更更复杂了
我们今天就不展开了
那么好了
有了这样的东西的时候
诶
我们是不是就开始可以写我们心爱的小网游了
对不对
我们可以做个对战游戏了对吧
大家都很想做对战游戏
诶
这里面有一个大家以前可能根本想不到的东西
就是说我们的在做网游之前
在做对战游戏之前
第一件事情是什么
我们得把彼此的时钟对准
大家可能没有想到对吧
为什么要做对战游戏
为什么要把时钟对准呢
因为很简单
就是我现在说我这个player
这个玩家A说
我在这个13秒零五打了一个一发子弹对吧
普莱尔B说我在13秒零六做了一把躲闪动作
我到底算是这个躲过了还是没躲过的呢
如果你们彼此的时间是没有对准的时候
你们觉得是不是大家彼此之间都不再说什么了
对吧
所以其实啊就这就是网络这个世界非常复杂的
就是还是哪个我用哪个MTUNIVERSE
就是多重宇宙的概念
就是在不同的宇宙里面
我们的时间都是不同步的
你看明天科民科又起作用了对吧
所以说相对论讲的所有东西
在我们游戏里面都会遇到
就是说每一个人的世界坐标系都是相
都是叫做什么
就都是相对坐标系
只是以以自我为中心的
那么多个universe之间的话
他们第一步就要把时钟序对准
那么好时钟怎么去对准呢
那么这里面就要理解
在网络上我们产生各种各样的问题
第一个呢大家知道有个概念叫RTT
叫round trip time
就是说我从我发一个包给对方多久时间
我能收到一个回报
诶
大家在哪个就是网络操作系统的时候
以前经常学的一个值叫什么叫ping值对吧
我们经常没事ping一下别人
然后收到别人的这个这个叫TTL对吧
这回回来一个值
那么RTT和ping值到底有什么区别呢
其实他们两个实际上非常的接近
但是呢如果你严格的死抠的话呢
是有那么一丢丢的区别
就是说ping值更底层一点
因为它是你的这个网络协议
这OS更底层可能是在传输层那一层
可能更下面一点
他们去做的所有的自我的检测
他们也通过上面的这个应用层和哪个表达层
但RTT呢很多时候是我们应用层自己写的
比如说我们一个游戏对吧
我的客户端发一个包过去给服务器
服务器多久回给我
我就能测试我的RTT
那么我可以就可以知道现在的网络的延迟情况
和他的latency
但是呢其实在游戏引擎这里面的话呢
很多时候你这两个字不用区分的那么的严格
而且对我们更有用的可能是RTT多一点
怎么去对视
其实这个问题啊是一个非常will sa problem
也不叫WILSON
是很重要的一个问题
大家想想看
其实这需要对时间这件事情啊
在全世界
这是一个极为关键的应用
为什么你可以比如说我们大家经常用的GPS对吧
GPS的本质原理是什么呢
就是在天上飞了24颗卫星
每个上面都装了极其准确的电子钟
然后呢你要你的GPS接收装置
你需要跟这些原子钟去收它的信号
然后他彼此之间呢是要对时的
然后呢你要有一个很精准的就是时间的相位差
你用三角定位法
就是你能算出你和他们彼此之间
距离的差是多少
这个时候你就可以算出我在地球表面的位置
所以其实我们在很多的系统
以免都要去定时的问题
但定时问题它最难就对时间这个问题对对
世界问题最难的一件事情是什么呢
就是说任何的信息传输是不能超过什么
不能超过光速的
对不对
当我北京的一个中说
现在是北京时间七点整
你拿你的表掏出来跟人家对的时候
我且不说你的反应速度
各种各样的速度吧
那你就这个北京
这个这个从北京时间七点整传到你这来的时候
你已经过了
大概可能是零点几百毫秒了对吧
所以说其实啊当然你会觉得我们在现实生活中
这个钟的话有这误差问题不是很大
但是对于这种GPS这种精密仪器来讲
这个影响是非常非常大的
所以呢其实有人专门研究这个东西
那么最经典的一个算法叫什么呢
叫NTP叫network time ple
就是哪个网络的时间的哪个协议
这个协议其实呢非常的简单
给大家讲一下
就是怎么去理解这个对视问题呢
哎这里面再讲个概念
就是对时
它很多时候是一层层的
它有个叫stratus
就是就像地层一样的
但这个就比较比较比较比较比较比较形而上了
就比如说我们有一个北京紫金山天文台啊
南京紫金山天文台最精准的一个天文钟对吧
那我们一层层的去对
一般来讲你好
原则上讲是这个据说超过了15层之后
这个这个钟就对的不准了
但是我们不用管那么细
其实在我们的网络游戏中的
很多时候
我们的STRATTON只有一层
就是你跟服务器对就好了
那你跟服务器怎么去对时间呢
啊这里面的话呢就跟大家讲一下
NTP算法的一个最基础的东西
它其实的基本原理非常的简单
就是说我从我的客户端在这个T0C的时间
就是C上面表示是client对吧
零就表示T0发出一个东西
就是这个T0C是什么
是我本地的时间
我发给谁呢
我发给服务器
服务器收到我的时候呢
就收到了
就TES我收到了
服务器根据自己的中枢哦
我在TE收到了你的这个时间
S stands for server
就代表server
那么过了一会儿
服务器说我给你再回一个
当然服务器经常会
它会在T这个二这个S的server的时间
把这个时间发给你
然后呢发给哪个包
然后呢你在什么呢
你在T3C的时候
就是在你本地的T3C的这个line的时间
就是你的科莱的这个密码收到这个包
当然在你这个包里面的话呢
实际上你的作为这个客户端
我这四个时间我都拿得到对吧
我这个包里把这四个时间都都扩大进去了
那这个时候呢
其实就有一个非常简单的一个算法
就是大家看到这个offset这个公式了对吧
这个公式的话其实就是一些简单的加减乘除
但这里面其实是有一个假设的
就是他会认为就是这个延迟的话
上行和下行基本是对称的对吧
然后呢你没有什么网络的波动
然后呢其实我可以根据你的上行和下行
我会估算出什么呢
估算出你的这个RTT是多少对吧
那我可以估计
因为我又知道你在服务器
在那边耽误了多少时间
其实我可以反向的算出来说
我跟你的这个就是说服务器之间的时差是多少
我这里举个更具体的一个例子啊
就大家比如说看到这里
比如说我在客户端
假设我在15.01分
17:01分哪个零零秒
我发个信息出去了
诶
服务器收到的时候说他是说诶
他是无哪个17:01:32
我收到了这个时间
你看好像这个消息不应该要走30分30秒
对不对
这大概率就是我的客户端给你的服务器
这个好像不太对付对吧
我们时间是不对的
好诶服务器说我在过了一秒钟之后
我在这个就是1分33秒给你传过来了
好客户端哪个时候过了一段时间我就收到了
但客户端这边显示什么呢
我这边显示的是什么呢
是这个这个时间是零五秒好了
这里面就是其实有些概念就非常有意思了
比如说我怎么算这个路途上的这个延迟
Delay
其实很简单
就是我发出去的时候
零一秒五秒钟后收到
让服务器告诉我说呢
他收到我的包和他发回来这个包之间
他花了一秒钟
所以呢我把服务器那边里面
消耗的时间给它剪掉
这样的话我可以算出来
说我在路上的弹幕就是五秒减去那个一秒
得到了四秒
好根据这个值我再看
如果有四秒的延迟
我理解
但是为什么到最后我这边显示的是零五秒
您这边告诉我
你发送的时间是33秒
对吧
我不可能你就是你不可能在未来发给我的消息
这时候我就要算一个offset
这个公式呢就是用前面那个公式
你会发现
就是说我的客户端那边的延迟和你相比的话
整整差我的钟跟你差了30秒
所以呢他基本能骨酸到一件事情
就是说如果按照这个延迟
比如说RTT是四秒的话
那我收到这个包的时间是什么呢
应该是你服务器时间的33+4除以二
就是7.35分
而我这边的话显示的是啊
那个那个1分35秒
而我这边显示的是1分05秒
我就知道了
我跟你差了30秒
我得赶快往前拨
追上你
所以你看到这个公式算出来你的offset是30秒
就算出来我的这个这个时间表
这里面其实这个公式非常好理解
很很容易解释
但是这里面其实有一个很危险的假设是什么呢
就是说诶
第一我认为网络的环境是整个稳定的对吧
我不会一会快
一会慢
第二个呢我假设什么呢
这个我发过去的这个延迟的时间
和他发过来的时间实际上是对等的
这件事情成不成名的大概率其实它是不成立的
为什么呢
因为大家想想看
就是在我们家里的网络
大家如果仔细看我们家的网络
哪个家庭网络里面有个特点
就是说你的下行带宽给的是很很高对吧
你下载片子时候非常快
对不对
你看的什么东西很快
但是呢你的上行带宽呢一般都比较窄
但是呢延迟的话
那就是真的不一定
有的时候是下行带宽延迟比较大
上限的话反而比较快对吧
所以你的上下两路它其实不一定是对等的
所以说其实这个NTP的
这个最基础的算法的话
他是要假设置两边是对等
它是用哪个RCT除以二
就估算了它的延迟
所以这也是这个算法呢它不太准确的地方
当然他肯定比你没有对的时候好很多
那真的对于我们的游戏引擎来讲的话
我们怎么去对视呢
其实这里面的话呢实话实说
这个就是信息论会告诉你
就是说在一个不可靠的链接的前提下
我们是无论你做多少次校对
你都没有办法把始终对准哎
这个东西大家如果有兴趣的话
可以用数学去证明一下
反正这件事情确实是你们要对准
但是呢我们可以尝试去猜
去逼近它
它怎么做呢
其实很简单
第一步我们把这个NTP算法跑一遍对吧
我们算出来说哎
我的客户端和服务器之间的差别
但是服务器是是跌
所以我跟他的时间对准
那这个时候呢唉我们会做一件什么事情呢
我先赶快把我的客户端的时钟给调一下
这个时候呢我就快速的
比如说做三次做啊
做五次做十次
多少次都可以
你只要愿意你跟他继续跑哪个NTP算法
你就算出一系列的offset
这里面就很有意思了
对吧对吧
就是你在前面第一步做完之后
如果假设这个网络符合我前面的假设
就是说它是一个稳定的上下行的呃
这个这个延迟都是对的呢
那我的钟就已经对准了呀
但实际上没有那么理想
网络数波动了
对不对对吧
你鬼才知道什么时候有种波动
没关系
我多做几次
每一次我都算出一系列的offset这个值
然后这个时候呢我去做一件什么事情
这件事情其实是非常hack了
就是说哎我把这里面所有的offset的值啊
包括这里面有RTT值
我也能算得出来
对不对
我把RT值最高于我平均值50%的这些
这个这些教时准校准的话呢
我们把它给扔了
诶
有意思吧
比如说我做五次或者做十次
中间有两三次
他的RT d值比我们RT平均值要高个50%
我就不认为它不可置信了
我就把它扔掉
这其实是个统计学的思路
对不对
那为什么RT t值高的值就被我扔掉了
其实很简单
就是因为这时候很显然网络在波动嘛
所以你这时候算出来offset就不可靠嘛
好他把这些可靠的这些RTD的情况下
我算出来的offset这个值呢做一个平均
再用它最后对这个中进行一次调整
那这个时候我就跳就完成了一次对表
所以其实啊这个方法
他其实用了一些统计学的概念
大家其实它的原理也很好理解
但是呢我们在做一个游戏
比如说我们任何一个客户端
开始跟服务器建立链接的时候
当握手成功的时候
一般你的第一件事情就是要把钟对起来
唉这件事情
所以说我们在讲这个游戏引擎课的时候
这我也是想变变成哪个online games
online games的第一part去讲
就是因为我个人觉得这件事情真的很重要
我因为我以前我们在做游戏引擎的时候
我们很多的bug可能是这个中配有对好导致的
就大家以后在处理一些比较对时间
敏感性的业务逻辑的时候
你会发现这件事情真的非常的重要
所以的话呢第一件事先把中队好
那么用这个NTB的算法
再加上这个简单这个策略的话
其实你能得到一个基本可靠的这样一个重
但实际上我们自己实践下来会发现还是误差
就这个误差呢
嗯有的时候还可能还不是那么容易被去除掉
但是这这已经没有办法了
其实我们已经没有办法去那个解决这个问题
因为真实的世界里面
这个网络链接比大家想象的要复杂得多得多
就是后面我们会简单提到
但实际上在这边的话呢
我们会只是让大家知道有个算法好
那么有了这样的一个中队又整了之后
接下来就看我们怎么去彼此通讯了对吧
那么这里面就讲个很有意思的概念呢
就是说其实呢这个前面讲的就是说
虽然OSI模型很复杂
七层模型对不对
我记得我在那个时候大学的时候学这个网
哪个计算机网络
这个这个这个架构的这门课的时候
那本书我记得是这么厚
然后我就觉得哎呀我的天呐
就做过网络怎么那么复杂呢
后来学着学着就发现我真的很复杂
考试的时候觉得哎真的好难对吧
但其实呢你有了socket编程之后也就很简单了
对不对
我们就找到彼此的这个IP地址嘛
找到pot嘛
然后一通数据传不就完事了嘛
对不对
一通塞数据嘛
但实际上当我们真的去写游
戏的这个业务逻辑的时候
我们就会发现这事儿真的不好使
就是为什么不好使呢
就是说其实啊我们再去表达一个
就是业游戏业务逻辑的时候
很多时候跟我们的人对话一样
就是说A服务器我想做一件什么事情
服务器说好
那我去做好
做完之后告诉过一会
告诉我说我已经做完了对吧
那你想想看
如果我们要用哪个
就是socket写这个网络消息的时候
其实呢我们会定义很多的消息
然后呢我经常代码写
写到一半说OK
我这个地方要send的一个消息出去了
好过下载完之后这个函数我要结束了
过段时间啊
等什么什么消息过来
我就一个回调一个函数
这个消息呢还他不它不仅仅是这个消息本身啊
消息里面还有很多的参数对吧
他要payload your parameter
然后我要对the parameter进行解析
那这里面的话呢就很蛋疼了
因为大家想想看
就是说当我们在写这个游戏逻辑的时候
你会发现就是说你要把这么多的
比如说我一会儿一个float
我一会儿一个vector4
就是我们一个空间的vector
一会儿是个颜色
一会儿可能是个矩阵
一会儿可能是一个哪个怪物的血量值对吧
一会儿是这个怪物的一个一个一样的一个类型
各种各样很奇怪的数据
我要把它打包成一个网络的协议发给别人
而且要把这个协议定义好
你想想看
作为一个程序员
你写到这一趴的时候
你就会觉得很难受
哎
反正我是很不喜欢写这个东西的
因为你会发现
如果就最早我们在最古老的时候
大家去理解游戏引擎那种
会想象
游戏引擎会定义一个巨长无比的消息列表对吧
但实际上的话这个列表是非常难以维护的
那么另外一个还有一个问题是什么呢
就是说其实啊客户端和服务器之间
他们的操作系统都是不一样的
比如客户端
很多时候我是在这个android的这个机器上
或者是IOS的电脑
是IOS的这个pad上面对吧
服务器一般是跑在LINUX上面
我们的这个这个语言都不一样
比如说我现在哪个
就是我们的哪个操作系统都不一样
那么有的时候呢
比如说举个例子啊
比如说我做一个主机游戏可以联网
Export the place playstation
大家知道这两个平台最反人类的地方是什么
就是我们前面已经提到过的
就是big ending
small ending的问题
就是说我的这个数据就是到底是高位在前
还是低位在前
对吧
我的packing都不一样
那这个网络传输的数据是不是就不一样了
对不对
那这里面就很麻烦
那包括就是说我有很多的数据我要去对齐
我要去把它packing在一起
因为在网络的时候
有的时候我们都尽量希望四个by的一一层嘛
那我一学primary传过去的时候
如果你只是顺序的压的话
哪个数据的话其实会很麻烦的
会形成像哪个狗啃的一样
就是数据一会长一会短
比如说我要把一个array传出去
那你这个消息怎么去定义呢
因为array是变长了对吧
那就很麻烦
你甚至有可能你要传一个数据
他可能要把很多东西拆下来
那等等这些所有的问题
其实啊当我们去写一个游戏业务逻辑的时候
你发现这些都在你的面前
而且你让一个写业务逻辑的程序员
去定义各种各样的消息
解决这些网络在传输的各种困难的事情的时候
你会觉得你让他做了一件
他其实特别不喜欢做的事
而且是特别容易做错的一件事情
因为你就想一个消息定义错了
那边收到了整个解析就乱七八糟的之后
那整个这边不就全
这个整个底层逻辑全部会炸掉
就是说大家想想看
就是我们在客户端和服务器通讯的时候
其实有一种攻击
就是我们会给服务器发出来各种各样的
就是乱码的数据
然后服务器呢它首先它要解谜
和它要解dio deck嘛
包括还有的时候是哪个
就是说description就是说解密
然后它可能会导致它会浪费大量的算力
解解码出来一个无效的信息
但是他又很难判断这个信息无效
这里面其实有很多很有意思的东西
在要去解决了
简单来讲的话
就是说其实这个地方是特别特别容易犯错的
所以呢这个时候就是RPC就remote procedure call
就横空而出
变态就是那么他的核心想法是什么呢
就是让程序员就像写自己的日常代码一样
我只是做一个函数的扩
然后呢我把我刚才传的参数传进去
剩下的事情
你是怎么把这个这个这个东西变成一个消息
去打包的
去package怎么去THALIZATION
然后你在网络怎么样的路由
到哪个对方的服务器
然后对方服务器怎么去接到这个消息
怎么去
就依次去处理
其实处理一个消息都很复杂
不是收到消息马上处理
他像是有个cash
有个pool对吧
然后再下一站pick up
然后呢再去怎么去处理它
怎么去distortion
这一系列所有复杂的东西跟我都没有关系
我一个RPC扣完之后
哎我该干嘛干嘛去了
然后呢你这边做完了之后
你再把我一个call回来
然后我来处理就完事了
所以这其实是一个非常了不起的发明
这里面举个简单的例子
就是用go语言的例子对吧
你会发现RPC的阔气很简单
就是你告诉我说诶我要扩server
比如说我的函数名是什么
我的parameter是什么
在server那边的话也有相应的函数诶
你只要这样一扩完之后
它通过一系列的这个消息的数据的准备传输
我也不知道你下面走的是什么协议
没关系
你就走走走走走走走
走到那边哎
到最后哪个函数就被激活了
很神奇吧
非常简单
但是呢
这个会极大地释放我们的程序员的开发效率
同时的话它不会出错
因为最怕的就是你的逻辑写错了
而且最怕的是你的数据进行packing的时候
数据一旦packing错之后
其实到那边就会非常的麻烦
所以的话呢就是说这是RPC一个非常重要的
就是说一个特性
而且RPC我个人的感受就是说
因为程序员他不需要再去向定义
哪个是structing structure
那样的去定义那种复杂的网络暴体结构
然后呢
他也不用担心这个ATIONDIRALIZATION的这个工作
因为在网络上很多是我们的数据都是加密的
对吧
还有很多加密和反加哪个解密解码的一个过程
实际上这些东西你全部都不用管
而且整个后台怎么处理的
全部对你透明了
所以这就让很多程序员能够专注的去写游戏
游戏逻辑
所以RPC呢是现代引擎最标准的一个practice
对好
那么这样一个东西你看上去很好用
那你怎么这里面就出现一个很有意思的东西了
叫什么呢
就是哎我们叫做interface definition language
就是那个就是叫界面定义语言idea
其实这个东西大家仔细想想
我们这里面举举个例子
比如像哪个google的political buffer这个概念对吧
它实际上大家我们在什么地方讲过
这个同样的东西
就是在工具哪个地方对吧
我们讲过schema的定义
这个地方它非常像schema的定义
就是说其实大家看我们的小引擎啊
你们定义的时候
其实很多时候这些比如说一个component的接口
是不是跟这个语言特别的现象
其实他们都是共通的东西
就是说其实为什么反射这件事这么重要呢
也就是说它不不仅在我们的工具侧
在我们的数据的THALIZATIONDISORATION上很有用
其实对于component也很有用对吧
对于网络也是非常用的
就是说其实我们所有网络的通讯
都通过这个idea的语言把它定义好之后
那接下来我们有一整套的这个东西去解决它的
就是函数指针的存储啊
解决了他这些数据的这个这个这个就是packing
哪个serialize和DISCIATION
所有的问题它全部给你处理好
所以这里面的话就会引入一个很有意思的概念
叫做rpc steps
stars呢
你简单来讲就是票据存根
就是说当我的一个客户端起来之后
当我哪个服务器起来之后
我们彼此会告诉对方我们的存在
然后呢我们就会注册一大堆的RPC
然后呢这样的话你的函数就知道了
说啊我有这么多的RPC可以调用对吧
而且你每次扣RPC的时候呢
它可以在这个RPC的存根里面去查
就是说如果这个RPC没有的话
系统还可以给你报错
很多系统做的比较好的
比如像游戏引擎的话
一般我们不会允许这个系统crush掉
我们只会给你报个错
说老哥你call了一个不存在的RPC对吧
你这个你这个哪个你回去查查一下去
但是呢我其他的业务逻辑该怎么走就能走
不会出问题
因为对于一个复杂的游戏来讲啊
实际上它的RPC非常的复杂
比如说动辄就是几百个以上的这个
RPC的这种各种的扩
那么而且呢游戏引擎的版本
游戏的版本一直在更新
所以很容易出现一个
比如说没有来得及更新的旧的这个比如说脚本
一段脚本哪一段代码对吧
他扩了一个错误的RPC
但是的话呢一般现代游戏引擎
它不会让你的游戏crush掉对吧
因为很多时候你说错了之后
只是某一个特定业务没有发声而已
但这件事情对于一个大的游戏来讲
它不会是个大问题
所以的话呢就是当我们定义了一堆的这种
RPC的接口之后
通过id定义的时候诶
我们有一个stop compiler对它进行编译
大家不是前段时间对哪个
就是那个我们的消引擎里面的schema的系统
很感兴趣嘛
其实schema系统
它本身也可以作为一个stop compiler对吧
但是呢如果你用的开源呢
比如说political buffer这种东西的话
它的compiler是现成的
对不对
所以这件事情其实是一个非常啊怎么说呢
大家解决的非常好的一个系统
所以其实它的基础的设计思想是非常通的
所以我就想你游戏引擎为什么特别有意思
就是你学到后面你会发现很多的设计思想
很多的方法它都是通的都在一起
所以这样的话就是说我们有了这个就是说id
我们就可以定义各种各样的RPC
而程序员的话
这个时候再去写各种各样的网络应用的时候
就可以像写本地代码一样的对吧
就可以扩很多远程的这样的应用就很方便
那么其实的话一个真实的RPC啊
才游戏引擎里面的路径没有那么简单
其实就像刚才我提到的
就是首先的话呢你的数据你跟RPC扩完之后
我要把你所有的参数给你进行THALIZATION
而且呢我还会对你进行压缩
很多时候我们需要压缩的
因为网络贷款很珍贵
所以我们要压缩一下
然后呢我们还加密
因为在就是在游戏里面的话
如果游戏就是客户端和服务器端的通讯
不被加密的话
那黑客就很容易去攻击的对吧
他可以在里面注入很多他想要的逻辑
所以的话我们一定要加密
所以的话呢就是说这样的话
到了服务器端的话
诶我们也是一样的过程
道路来一遍对吧
我想要解密
然后呢我要去解压缩
然后呢我还要再进行这个DISCIALIZATION
这样我那边的所有的相应的函数就被扩了
当然有些RPC呢
它是通过我们讲的这种a reliable ud p出来的
比如说游戏业务相关
有的有的有的哪个就是那个就是RPC呢
他可能是通过什么呢
哎通过TCP连过来
就像我们前面讲过很多时候
比如说账号登录啊
这些东西
我们去保证我们哪个握手
就是客户端和server端的握手成功
所以这个呢是一个真实的RBC在底层走的
这样的过程怎么样
讲了大概差不多一个小时20分钟了
同学们会会不会很着急
说哎
为什么到现在还没有教我一点点怎么去做游戏
讲了半天
我只是学了一些网络协议
怎么架构对吧
知道一个RPC的东西
还知道了怎么去对对表
对时钟知道这么多
为什么游戏我还不会做
唉对你没有这些基础的话
说实话作为一个游戏引擎的
这个就是online gaming
游戏引擎的话呢
你还真是做不了
因为这些都是最基础的东西